Narrator: What do you think of when
you hear the word poison?
Arsenic?
Cyanide?
How about water?
Life couldn't exist without water,
but in the right circumstance,
water can be as dangerous as any poison.
Your kidneys filter out
excess waste and water
from your bloodstream.
But they can only process
800 to 1,000 milliliters
of water an hour, and
if you somehow managed
to drink more than that
without throwing up,
you could run into trouble.
Because you're drinking faster
than your kidneys can process it.
So the excess ends up in your cells.
Normally, your cells are
surrounded by a carefully balanced
solution of sodium and
water, which flows in and out
through tiny holes in
the cellular membrane.
So it keeps the sodium
concentration, both in and out
of the cell, balanced.
But when you drink too much water,
the sodium solution gets diluted.
It's not salty enough.
So some of that excess
water rushes into the cell
to restore balance.
And that causes it to swell up.
Doctors call this water intoxication,
and it's a big problem.
Now, most of your cells can
handle the swelling to a degree,
since soft, flexible tissue
like fat and muscle can stretch.
But for the cells in your
brain, it's another story,
because your skull isn't stretchy.
It's bone.
It's hard, like a rock.
So, as your brain swells it
builds up pressure in your head.
At first you might experience
headaches, confusion,
or drowsiness, but as
the pressure increases,
you risk brain damage,
coma, and even death.
And it could all be over
in less than 10 hours.
A 64-year-old woman for
example, died the same evening
after drinking between 30
to 40 glasses of water.
And a group of US Army trainees suffered
vomiting and seizures after
downing over two liters
per hour after a tough day of training.
But it's marathon runners who
need to be especially careful.
A study found that one
in six marathon runners
develop at least mild water intoxication,
because the race stresses their body,
including the kidneys.
So they don't excrete
water as efficiently,
which can cause water to back
up into the blood more easily.
And the problem isn't unique to water.
For example, the same thing can happen
if you down too much beer at once.
That's called potomania.
The good news is, severe
water intoxication is rare,
and is more likely to
happen in people who have
kidney issues, since
they can't process water
properly to begin with.
Plus, there is an easy way to stay safe.
The average healthy adult
needs somewhere around
three to four liters of water a day.
And since this can come from food
and other drinks too,
drink when you're thirsty,
and then stop.